ach ja was heute versuchen wir zu den
rätseln was der ausdruck achim deutschen
eigentlich bedeutet
es ist eine prima idee ja dadurch sagen
was geht
ok
achte das eigentlich wenn man erstaunt
es wenn man wenn man den begriff hat wo
man sagt das ist aber komisch ja wo man
selbst mit noch nicht klar ist so dieser
ausdruck man kann seufzen zur
erleichterung man kann jemanden bedauern
gut das ist auch ein bisschen
was sagen wir noch zu acht wundern ach
ja und was sagt man wenn man sich freut
mit ach ist das schön ja wenn schönheit
zu ja wenn man wenn man wenn man nicht
als sehr sehr sehr gut an findet ja ja
ich denke es ist ein ausdruck der
verhinderung geben sie mir ein paar
beispiele
ach ist eine interaktion und hat
tatsächlich mehrere bedeutungen
ach kann zum beispiel ärger ausdrücken
januar stößt seine handschuhe vergessen
ach verdammt
ach kann auch verwunderung oder
überraschung ausdrücken
kari wusstest du dass die erde rund ist
ach so ich dachte man die wärme scheibe
kari wusstest du dass das fliegen und
schlecht für die umwelt ist
ach ja das habe ich ja noch nie gehört
übrigens wenn ihr euer deutsch
verbessern möchtet dann probiert doch
mal unsere app ceiling aus dort könnt
ihr nämlich nicht nur die deutsche
grammatik schritt für schritt lernen
sondern auch an eure eigenen aussprache
arbeiten und zwar könnt ihr eure
aussprache aufnehmen und sie dann mit
der aussprache von muttersprachlern
vergleichen
ach gott
zum beispiel oder ach herrje jaja das
verlangt neben ganzen immer noch einmal
ausdruck dass man kann auch sagen ach
herrje
wenn man sagt wenn du mal schief
gelaufen ist nur was ja jetzt wissen sie
ja das kommt vom herr jesus ist mir
jetzt eingefallen religiöser flucht
was sagen sie wenn sie enttäuscht
also ich würde wahrscheinlich sagen auch
schade ja oder ach schade aber auch sagt
man dann häufig ja auch wenn ich sage
ach ist es meistens wenn entweder wenn
ich irgendwas verstanden habe was der
andere sagte oder oder ach ja oder
manchmal sagt man auch wenn man etwas
verleihen möchte also wenn wir genau so
also das kann viele bedeutungen haben
tatsächlich ja mit acht kann man auch
abwertungen ausdrücken oder zeigen dass
etwas nicht so wichtig ist
kari ich brauche schon wieder eine neue
gitarre
ach ja nicht acht sondern ja und acht
kann auch resignieren sein aber das kann
auch manchmal positiv sein wie zum
beispiel in diesem beispiel
jetzt habe ich meine handschuhe
vergessen und jetzt bin ich doch in die
hinterste getreten
ach ja und wenn man sich ärgert na ja
das würde weniger benutzen aber kann man
auch sagen ach das ist aber ärgerlich ja
diesen begriff kenne ich auch aber macht
man selten
also ich jedenfalls aber mit mit wenn
man sich freut und wenn man irgendwie
stützt auch fassungslos was jetzt
passiert diesen in dieser hinsicht ja
wir hoffen er ist jetzt wie man auch im
deutschen benutzt und was es bedeutet
und uns würde interessieren gibt es
dieses wort auch in euren sprachen
schreibt uns mal einen kommentar dazu
und wenn ihr euer deutsch verbessern
möchte dann laden wir euch unbedingt ein
dazu lernen uns voll mit unserer elf sie
länger dort könnt ihr nämlich die
grammatik schritt für schritt
kennenlernen zum beispiel mit lustigen
geschichten mechanisch und ihr könnt
auch die deutsche aussprache lernen
indem ihr nämlich eure eigene aussprache
aufnimmt und mit muttersprachlern
vergleicht probiert das mal aus wir
freuen uns euch bald wiederzusehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]